hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome another
edition of ask Evan in today's episode
I'm going to answer question from one of
my four meters Jason we've seen a couple
times before now and he wants me to
check out his landing page in sales
letter for new program that he's
launching called how to be real
blueprint so I thought I'd crittenton
video and help him out so he has two
lengths one is to a landing page who
wants to a sales letter so we'll open
both and the first thing I know stood
for was that the sales letter page is
not found so there's a broken link
somewhere so can't help you much here on
this one Jason but looking at the other
one this is a video that basically
explains the program a little bit it's
talking about how to be yourself and you
know why you could be afraid of being
yourself and why it's important I like
that message there is a lot of people
who are afraid to be themselves and it
is a good competitive differentiation
when you can be yourself when you bring
that to your business then you're much
more likely to be successful than if you
try to act as somebody else so I think
there's a there's a message in there and
if you can help people with that then
that could be really useful for them as
a does they try to grow I scroll down
here and this doesn't really captivate
me my screen is a little bit smaller
here that I'm recording because the
dimension is just a little smaller but
my actual screen I would see this
normally above the scroll and this is
where the scroll ended for me so it's
imagine meeting that person you look up
to your idol you're finally plus with a
meeting and the first thing they ask you
is who are you and to me that's not
really a big pain point I really liked
it you're talking about higher up on the
page about you know being yourself and
learning why that matters and being real
i think that's important but then this
down here doesn't really grabbed me so
if i just hit on this page myself i
would probably leave that quickly
because this main message which is a lot
bigger than the message above doesn't
really pull me the other thing you'll
find a lot is people may not necessarily
read this if you find a small text above
a video or picture you'll find that the
article gets drawn down here to the
video
and this might get missed so this is
what actually is most interesting for me
and that was below so you might want to
just work on this this text a little bit
as you scroll down you see that it's a
really long form text so there's a lot
of these types of products that are out
there you what you run the danger of
being associated with internet marketing
products which are usually seen like
this and there's a lot that are not
really great quality so you want to be
careful you know that you don't fall
into that trap a little bit it is
clearly laid out so yeah your eye
doesn't get too tired just pictures it's
it's laid out well with there's no
difference in colors and things are
bolded some things aren't it's great to
see that there's testimonials on here so
it's people that you know you can read
and it shows their name their full name
it shows what they do below it shows
some of their websites so that's really
great again pretty easy to read here
it's broken up well so that goes on gone
more testimonials etc quotes it's great
what I didn't get the sense of here is
who your target market is and I know
we've talked about this a little bit in
the forms apart from what I'm covering
this video so talk about who your target
market is who this can help instead of
helping everybody if you can focus on a
particular market you're much more
likely to be able to speak to them and
their pain points any more likely to get
people to take that next step whatever
action you want them to take so this
course is for you if blah blah blah not
for you if these things it's great but
what what I don't see here is what what
do you want me to do like what's my next
step if people can sign up for this or
you know the only thing here is if you
have questions contact me so it'd be
great to see what the next step is if
it's just a landing page for now get
people on a leave their email to opt-in
so that you can contact them when you
launch that that might help you know in
terms of your conversions overall looks
interesting again I would work on the
top if people don't like what they see
at the top here they're going to bounce
right away so it make this a little bit
more talking to the pain
of people I don't know if meeting your
idol and them asking who are you is
really going to be a huge pain point for
a lot of people so I might switch that
up and talk about some of the pain
points that you really helped solve our
assume your course talks a lot more
about you know how people can get
confidence in themselves and develop
their message and then they're saying
what they believe and what they stand
for instead of what they're going to
tell their idol if they meet them so
that's what I would try to focus on in
just a sales presentation and I think
you'll get a much better chance of
getting people to convert but make sure
you have something on there about
conversion to at the end okay so that
would really help in terms of getting
the momentum built up for this launch so
good luck Jason to help the video helped
and keep me posted with how you do with
it for everybody watching if you liked
the video please give it a thumbs up
below and it'd be great to hear your
comments let me know you think about
this website let me know what you've
done in the past if you have any
thoughts or questions and be great to
hear from you in the comments below so
thank you and we'll see you on the next
episode
you